Hello everybody my name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Freddy Fazbear's Pizzeria Simulator!
Now, we are in a whole lot of trouble.
[chuckle] I mean, that's- that's self-evident in and of itself. We- we've made some questionable decisions
and we've got a lot of
Animatronics that are ready to crawl up our own anoOOses and tear us apart from the inside out
which is a weird sentence that I thought I'd never have to say in my life, but here we are! So I'm gonna evaluate-
what I'm gonna be doing here, and I'm gonna look very closely at Lally's Lollies apparently
I'm gonna be looking very closely at the ins and outs of what we actually need here, but first
I'm gonna go win myself some tokens
and uh- get some more money.
Because that's what I need right now.
OH but I- What is a data archive??
What's an Egg Baby Data Archive???
I wanna find out. I spent a lot of money on that thing, better be good
[nervous chuckle] You're blocking the view of the.. the duck pond I can't
What's a Data Archive?!
What?! What did I just spend my money on?
All right then can I can I play and get a balloon?
I'M READY!
GIMME A BALLOON
[Air horns, Mark screeching]
Got a balloon!
Alright- ok that was- that was a thing ok
ya know what [x2]
Get this shit outta here.
We've got better and bigger and greater prizes like this!
Not that, let's, let's go with not that.
This!!
YES
OOOOOH NOOOOOOO!!! [back-snapping sound]
It dead.
Woah.
Wait! Whoa whoa okay? There's a face, hey
Hey, now. There's a face..
All right. Wow all right. [off key singing] There's a face in the background of this game! There is a face
Right there, I saw it- hello who you- is that me? what the hell is that-
Is this supposed to - woAh I don't like that.. at all. I'm so fast
OK, all right
aaaAH. I'm so faaast!
AAAh. Oh boy. AAAAY FRUIT MANIA! I'm maniac! Oh go- ohh..
Hang on a second here
Wait there's something going on here. Why- why is
Why is there.. why is there a face in the background and why oh?
Why is?
Why- I'm just- there's so many questions of 'why' that I has?
aee- zoom aee-
Don't go out of bounds cuz apparently that's terrible for you. Okay, I gotta get - eugh not there. Oh. What was that?
That I just saw?? Wait a minute. Wait. I- oh hi. What are you and why are you there?
And what are you doing, and who do you think you are?
Hey, that's a slug. --way to get to you. How do you get to you? Hey, whoa
OK. All right.
Wow. Hello..
Dammit. AA- shitty.
Goober gabber!
Aah! Slug. Slug! SLUG!
OWW. Oh no, slug of invisa- oHH that's handy, that. That is very handy.
Aah. Ooh. Okay, well, I'm about to win I guess. I found some lonely fruits.
AAAY! I did it! I got an amazing. I don't know what that means. What does that mean? OK, all right. Well... [breathes in sharply] good
I'mma geett-I'm gonna get.. I'm gonna get Foxy! OK, I'm gonna get Foxy. 'Cause I like Foxy and uhh-
You know who I don't like? This pig, and I just, I just don't.  Foxy's there.
He-he-he-hey! Foxy on the left, Left-Lefty on the right. Let's do this bad boy. I'm gonna die! Okay.
We're gonna get into the thick of the game and this time
I know how to play! Kind of. A little bit
But not entirely so I'm gonna just do this to the best of my ability and NOT die.
While also listening out for the things in the duh-duh dark waiting for me
Okay, I can't hear shit.
Ooh. Ooh. Ah. Ooh. [weird grunting noise] you gonna? Gah?
[relief sound]
Hey. You can go away now.. That's right. Excellent.
Ooh. Hey, how's it going? over there- in the other vent. You can go away, too.
Okay, any time now. You can go away. Assume you went away. [loud ad music] AAAH! NOOO!! Ooska- alright!
Hey, you didn't hear that annoyingly loud
advertisement, did you? That I shouldn't have taken because advertisements are very bad for me. For my health actually
[more loud ad music] OOHH NOT THE WACKY WART!!
Nope. [grunt]
Hey, how's it goin? You remember me, the guy who wasn't making any noise over here?
Yeah, you can forget all about me, and how I don't exist
Ah, I hate this, I hate this, I hate this, I hate this- go cup, it's just cups!
[Funtime Freddy’s laugh echo]
Okay, HAHAHAHA! We're all laughing at funny jokes over here! Funny, funny man over there! Being as funny as-
[Loud AD Tune] ooHHH LALLY. LALLY LOLLIE.
Uh oh.
That ain't good. [quiet banging noise] AAAAH! IS IT BEHIND ME OR IN FRONT OF ME? I DON'T KNOW!
[Distressed noise]
I don't know. I don't know, but I'm alive. Amazingly-
Let's make as much noise as possible! Right in the now!
Okay, okay, okay, okay? Go go go go go-
[moan]
Okay. Alright, everything seems fine. I don't know why.
COME ON! AAAAH!! [ad music plays] NO MARTY!! MARTY YOU'RE NOT-
Springtrap: What is this? A promise such as this..
Mark: I don't know which way. I don't know which way. wooOAH. No.
nu no no
Ah, why??   Baby: Where are you?
I'm nowhere! And everywheeere!
That's how it works in the show business? oh I'm so boned
Okay, well I'm boned. I'm boned. I'm boned. I'm boned. I'm boned. It's a good thing I'm great at this game.
It's a good thing I'm really good at this game. Hey. I hear you crawling squeak squonking over in the vents
I'll have none of that. Thank you
Let's go loud push. Why not why not why not cuz I'm ballsy yeah, everybody shut up for a second
I hear that come on. Hey. How's it going over there? riIIAHHHH
I'm nothing. I'm no one no one. I'm no one to nobody
Something tells me I hear screaming happening in the hallways which is bad- probably
All right everything's fine, everything's 100% hunky dukey
Everything's a hu- [inaudible] Everything’s hundreds of percenples
everything's BLEH BLEH
Ooooh. Well... I'm just gonna turn it back off- Hang on,
Just as a precautionary measure
Come on... CLEAN THOSE OVENS! CLEAN 'EM GOOD. SCRUB A DUB BUB. SCRUB A DUB-- ooh
[Groan] I heard that on my left. But I'm gonna risk it! I'm risking it! WHY AM I RISKING IT?! OH!
Heard that on my right too.
oh... heard that
Heard that. I heard all of that
Spring Trap: You may not recognize me at first
Mark: OH
Springtrap: But I assure you
Springtrap: That's still me
Mark: NO [lets breath out]
I don't think so
I don't know who it is. I don't know who and where and what and wHYYY.
NO! Stop going in the vents. I don't have TIME for this. It's gonna get real TOASTY up in here.... I think he's fine.
Why?! I just... heard it again. But, I think it's okay I'm gonna order a quick supply
AHHHH. I HEARD ANOTHER LAUGH.
FUCK IT! AH! I heard you!
Okay [mumbling] that's no good
Okay, we're good. We're good. Get the utensils! Get the utensils! Get those uTONSELS
UTUNDELOOS
I JUST HEARD THAT! NO!
You move you move
There you go, that's it that-a-boy that-a-boy
Oh, yeah, thatta boy. That-a-boy. Pizza Kits! That one really wants
REALLY WANTS.... IN.. HERE
ugh [x2]
Either that was you sliding in or sliding out? I don't know which ooOOWOAH WOAH WOAH WOAH WOAH-- HEY... WOAH LEFTY
LEFTY! IF THAT'S YOU LEFTY! I AIN'T ABOUT THAT!
OKAY! ALRIGHT. OR YOU CAN JOIN IN TOO RIGHTY!  WHY ARE BOTH? WHY BOTH? WHY BOTH? WHY WOULD WE DO BOTH?
okay... that was a slide out noise i think...
Was that a slide back in?
[Baby Jumpscare] OOOOH! GOD! COME ON!
Baby: "It feels like... my birthday..."
awwwwwww
Baby: "Did you have a gift for me?"
awwww man
I was doing good... I was doing good.
Man, I only.... I only had so much left.
Oh shit... I was going so gOOOOD.
Titty Sprinkles. This is... eugh... this is hard.... okay.
So, I gotta get the hard ones out of the way first. I think that's just guarenteed
[Groan] Cause otherwise, I'm just gonna be boned forever.
That's a little early to be a douche.
[loud ad plays]
Hi Lally... You gonna be a dick the whole TIME LALLY
Come on. Print it. Print it. Print it.
[Honk, honk, honkhonkhonk] Honka hONKA. HONKA TONKA HONKA.
So there's a noise for them going-- Springtrap: "Who could resist" in-
Springtrap: "A promise such as this."
Going into the vent, and coming, like just into the hallway just outside the vent.
They're different sounds.
But I think they all relate. Much like sister location- uh- 20 mode.
They all do kind of relate.
Yeah, see that was just entering the hallway. oooh, woah, woah
That was entering the vent.
There's so many things to do!
There's always-- what was that? Wait, did I hear?
Woah. Both sides. That's a new one Oh. I'm dead. I'm dead. I'm dead.
[Springtrap Jumpscare] Oh! Fuu--- Goddammit! God!
Springtrap: "Bittersweet but fitting"
ughhh god dammit
I'mma get this. I got this. I got this.
I don't care how hard it is. I don't care. I'm gonna do it.
Maybe, turning the computer off isn't always-
the best opt--
[Baby Jumpscare] AAAAAH! OOOOOOH. OKAY! MAYBE IT IS. Maybe it is.
Baby: "You should have known I'd find you."
But-- I think, I think there's something about having the computer on. To be able to check where they are
Turning the computer off is a good thing.
But, also... I can just turn the fan off because that creates most of the noise.
Which, is what leads them to me!
[loud ad plays] ugh
Okay
That's how Wacky Warty's gonna play it.
Well I don't play by that shit.
Not at all.
I'm a man of patience.
I'm a patient man.
One more.
Just one more.
That's right... You walk away.
You walk away...
You walk away.
You have no need to be here.
Walk Away.
HEYOOOOO! I'M OUTTIE BABY! HOLY SHIIIIIIITAKE!!!
GOD! This is so stressful. I can't even explain how stressful it is!
Just because, like... it's so tense! And I have to listen so quietly! And you have to be very, very patient!
You can't rush, or else you gonna be dead!
Ay yi yi.  At least Lefty
How many new lawsuits do we have?! How many new ones? How many new ones?
Hoooh boy! Look at us. Yaaaay.
Ooooooooh....yaaaAAAAY
WOW. I don't believe that, for a second.
Oooooh. More!
Oh! I guess it's just-
This is just life now-- Hey! Marked down!
WOW!
Look at that!
Huh. So I guess, we just gotta save up until we get...
What we need!
It was surprising that there's no, big lore stuff this time around.
But, that's because the big day is tomorrow.
In the game, it's Saturday. And they told me that,
I need to have everyone in one place.
Which is, SO FUN AND HAPPY! AND DEFINITELY NOT MURDEROUS IN ANY WAY AT ALL.
But, that's what we're gonna find out in the next video. So, look forward to that.
Thank you everybody, so much for watching. Let me know what you think, down in the comments below.
And, as always! I will see you in the next video.
BUH-BYE!